olivia de havilland madame la présidente
devrais je dire souvent l'écho médias
aiment passer derrière la caméra et
devenir metteur en scène il leur arrive
aussi parfois de faire partie d'un jury
comme vous ici à cannes
connaissant vous les difficultés du
métier cela risque de vous influencer de
vous faire voir uniquement le travail
qui a été fait davantage que le résultat
il me semble quand je joue je sais bon
public et je joue j'ai un film quand
même au comme un homme une oeuvre d'art
plutôt comme les les spectateurs
assez sensible expérimenté vous estimez
vous même à vouloir tourner beaucoup
d'oeuvres d'art à hollywood
ça peut arriver vous savez à hollywood
j'ai eu la chance de tourner autant en
emporte le vent la fosse aux serpents
est l'héritière
et je crois tous les toits comme des
oeuvres d'art
je suis fâché ris je crois j'espère que
nos et j'habite la france et ça me donne
je suis né au japon
anglaise d'origine anglaise je suis
américaine par naturalisation et
j'habite la france jeune fille française
même et j'espère que j'ai un point de
vue un peu influencé par le fait que ma
vie a été sonné donc plusieurs pays et
j'espère que je comprends la mentalité
là psychologique des différents peuples
oui vous ne risquez pas de vous souvenir
trop que vous avez été vous êtes
toujours une grande vedette d'hollywood
pour juger par exemple mieux les films
américains que les autres
de m'attraper monsieur je suis je
serrais comme dans sur tous les plans de
la vie de rester qu'est ce que l'on peut
dire je cuis objectif est de faire des
jugements d'équité
[Musique]